[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 2020 se le está complicando y mucho a
donald trump más de 100 mil muertes por
el coronavirus en eeuu millones de
desempleados y un montón de protestas en
las calles contra el racismo y la
violencia policial
y puede que ya lo hayamos olvidado pero
recordad que a principios de año tram se
enfrentó incluso a todo un impeachment
un envite del que salió victorioso pero
durante el cual le dijeron de todo menos
bonito no
es que racing en elección de equipo en
south end of sports de montevideo en de
extracto bailes jon jones out of the
lake en emerging vamos que se puede
decir más alto pero no más claro y ojo
porque si pensáis que esta acusación es
ya grave lo más importante es saber
quien la formula porque amigos estas
palabras no fueron pronunciadas por un
líder de la oposición sino por todo un
senador del partido republicano y no
precisamente un senador cualquiera se
trata ni más ni menos que de mitt romney
uno de los personajes políticos más
importantes del partido político que
respalda las decisiones y la legislación
de la administración trump así que ante
el impeachment romney tuvo que tomar una
difícil decisión elegir entre mantener
su propio criterio o respetar la
disciplina de partido
[Aplausos]
mitt romney no es un senador cualquiera
tiene una larga trayectoria política en
el partido republicano fue gobernador
del estado de massachusetts participó en
las primarias presidenciales de 2008 y
fue el candidato republicano que se
enfrentó a la reelección de obama en
2012 desde el año pasado además es
senador republicano por yuta para un
mandato de seis años un cargo en el que
podría estar hasta enero del 2025
amigos trampas super olympics mein entre
otras cosas porque sus compañeros de
filas votaron mayoritariamente en contra
de testimonios que podrían haber
resultado claves testimonios como por
ejemplo el de john bolton consejero de
seguridad nacional en la propia
administración trap por este motivo no
son pocos los analistas que consideran
que ese día el partido republicano se
rindió definitivamente al tram mismo sin
embargo el voto rebelde de romney dejó
abierta una pequeña grieta en la coraza
republicana de donald trump una grieta
de la que ahora tras la reciente crisis
del 2020 se han sumado más cargos
republicanos
y amigos una pregunta empieza a estar en
el aire puede haber una alternativa
trump puede ser el senador polillita la
punta de lanza de un nuevo movimiento
llamado a derrotar al tram mismo y ojo
porque lo último que sabemos es que
romney ha participado en las marchas
contra el racismo dirigidas en
washington hacia la casa blanca
y sabéis que si ve algo puede presumir
romney es precisamente de coherencia y
honestidad nada más llegar al cargo del
senador cuando ni siquiera sabíamos que
iba a haber un impeachment contra el
presidente romney ya pronosticaba cómo
gestionaría su lealtad hacia trump en
general siguió el manual republicano
entonces estaré con él donde no estaré
con él de vez en cuando serán asuntos de
conducta o comunicación que considero
altamente divisivos o misógeno o
antiinmigrantes en esos casos creo que
es importante para mi integridad
personal ponerme de pie y decir no no
estoy de acuerdo con eso mitt romney y
senador republicano por yuta amigos
valen posiblemente la oportunidad de
rowling para ser presidente de eeuu ya
pasó pero su influencia puede llegar a
ser muy importante en el futuro del
partido republicano por eso hoy en
visual político vamos a repasar su
trayectoria sus enfrentamientos con el
presidente y sus posiciones políticas
atentos
[Música]
el rey midas
dromi y donald trump tienen algo en
común los dos son millonarios más que
billonarios multimillonarios pero hasta
aquí llegan las semejanzas entre ambos
mientras que trapero es un tipo de
propenso al show y a la ostentación
romney es todo lo contrario la palabra
escándalo no está asociada a su nombre
hablamos de un tipo discreto con una
vida familiar ejemplar y además muy
marcada por la religión de hecho a lo
largo de su trayectoria política se ha
debatido mucho pero que mucho sobre esta
última cuestión porque romney es mormón
y menos del 2% de los estadounidenses
son mormones así que muchos se
preguntaban si los prejuicios religiosos
podrían actuar en su contra dado su
recorrido político está claro que no fue
el caso
el padre de mitt romney fue gobernador
de michigan y miembro del primer
gobierno de richard nixon parece claro
que pertenecer a una familia tan
influyente fue una importante ventaja
sin embargo el senador por yuta no
perdió el tiempo tras graduarse en las
escuelas de derecho y negocios de la
prestigiosa universidad de harvard
arrancó una exitosa carrera como hombre
de negocios fijaos después de una breve
temporada en el boston consulting group
romney fue fichado por una consultora
rival
in and company y fue el escogido para
liderar el lanzamiento de bing capital
actualmente uno de los fondos de
capital-riesgo más importantes del mundo
como inversor romeo y respaldo firmas de
enorme éxito como staples una cadena de
suministros de oficina y la mundialmente
conocida domino's pizza estos méritos
llevaron a que romney fuera finalmente
nombrado el ceo de bein company todo
ello le permitió acumular una fortuna de
más de 200 millones de dólares amigos en
eeuu hay un estado donde los mormones
son mayoría yuta su capital es salt lake
city pues bien a finales de los años 90
se hizo público que las autoridades de
salt lake city habían sobornado a un
montón de miembros del comité olímpico
internacional para organizar los juegos
olímpicos de invierno del 2002 aquello
fue un escándalo tremendo que sacudió al
deporte mundial al olimpismo y que dejó
muy tocado al comité organizador nadie
absolutamente nadie quería patrocinar
aquellos juegos y vincular su nombre a
la corrupción el prestigio digital
estaba el juego y la pregunta es que
hicieron entonces
pues acudir a romney para evitar el
desastre nombraron a esta especie de
nuevo rey midas que entonces dirigía a
la reina en campana y como el máximo
responsable del comité organizador
querían que en aquellos juegos el oro
fuera para la organización y sabéis que
romney lo consiguió eliminó un déficit
de casi 400 millones de dólares y logró
que al final salt lake city-2002 pues un
gran éxito de logia dow por el comité
olímpico internacional
si lo habéis escuchado bien romney
consiguió un auténtico milagro unos
juegos olímpicos que no fueran una ruina
gente de américa yuta y salt lake city
le han dado al mundo unos juegos
excelentes nos han asegurado que las
personas de todos los países puedan
vivir pacíficamente juntas gracias
jacques rogge presidente del comité
olímpico internacional en la ceremonia
de clausura de sally sitio 2002 el
beneficio de los juegos olímpicos de
invierno es de 56 millones de dólares y
amigos este éxito hizo que romney
saltará de nuevo en la palestra política
y digo saltará de nuevo porque ya había
optado previamente a ser senador pero
enfrente tuvo al eterno senador por
massachusetts ted kennedy ni más ni
menos que hermano de jfk y durante
décadas uno de los grandes capos del
partido demócrata así que no tuvo
ninguna opción
sin embargo ahora las cosas habían
cambiado y además cuando fue elegido
gobernador de massachusetts demostró que
su fama de rey midas era merecida fijaos
se encontró un presupuestario de tres
mil millones de dólares y apenas dos
años más tarde ya tenía un superávit de
unos 700 millones
[Música]
su mayor logro además fue su reforma de
la atención médica una reforma que
negoció con la oposición demócrata aquí
entonces dominaba la cámara legislativa
de este estado con esta reforma romney
puso en marcha un sistema que obligaba a
todos los ciudadanos a contratar un
seguro médico privado para resolver el
problema social más apremiante del
estado la falta de cobertura médica de
los no asegurados por supuesto las
personas que no contaban con los
suficientes recursos para contratar una
póliza recibían ayuda del estado es un
modelo con bastante sentido nos parece
que con él se garantiza que todo el
mundo tenga cobertura médica se estimula
la competencia entre las aseguradoras y
las economías de escala son mayores lo
que permite reducir los costes de las
pólizas o mejorar el servicio y además
el coste para el estado es relativamente
reducido pues 677 sensor me instruyan
sólo para abrir más respecto y fuerza
las nóminas del profe de forma activa al
ser el ford andan en ventajas por el
experto en semanales del power-pop y por
ningún lado están twitter
el padre will we the state los saps
horas después otro de los wizards rights
project and away we care in sur
romney era toda una estrella política en
ascenso así que renunció a buscar la
reelección como gobernador para
concentrarse de lleno en las primarias
republicanas
sin embargo lo cierto es que llegó tarde
la sucesión de bus para cuando el diego
ya estaba claro que john mccain sería su
heredero pero de todas formas goma
arrasó en aquellas presidenciales y
romney y se puso a trabajar
inmediatamente para tener una nueva
oportunidad los ideales estadounidenses
de libertad y oportunidad económica
necesitan una defensa clara y sin
complejos yo pretendo defenderlos porque
los he vivido
mitt romney finalmente en 2012 nuestro
protagonista de hoy no tuvo rival en las
primarias republicanas y lo que es muy
importante las elecciones
estadounidenses su campaña tuvo una
financiación enorme por cierto entre los
apoyos empresariales de romney hubo
algunos como definirlos inestables
twitter es duro es inteligente es fuerte
no permitirá que continúen sucediendo
cosas malas en este país que todos
amamos entonces gobernador ron y sal y
consíguelo puedes hacerlo
donald trump en 2012 mitt romney es un
hombre confuso que no tiene ni idea no
es de extrañar que perdiera donald trump
en 2016 bueno creo que todos conocéis ya
a donald trump y su cuestionable
relación con la verdad y la coherencia
el caso es que efectivamente
ante obama y como ya sabéis el partido
republicano cayó después en manos de
trama sin embargo amigos si hay alguien
que nunca fue fan del actual inquilino
de la casa blanca ese fue precisamente
mitt romney atentos un republicano con
principios le entraba el perfil de
romney era perfecto para alcanzar la
casa blanca sin embargo tenía un pequeño
problema le faltaba carisma entre los
estadounidenses posiblemente romney es
alguien que se desempeñaría mejor como
presidente que como candidato algo
insalvable cuando tu rival es un tipo
tan mediático tan escénico y tan popular
como barack obama
y además la propaganda demócrata
consiguió presentar a romney como un
alto ejecutivo sin ningún tipo de
escrúpulos alguien capaz de despedir a
su madre con tal de aumentar los
beneficios de la empresa
en version euro with the disabled
lo interesante no obstante es que algo
estaba cambiando en el alma del partido
republicano atentos al discurso de clint
eastwood en la convención republicana
del 2012
vive y a veces para
[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo malo cliente es que los
estadounidenses prefirieron el marketing
de obama y cuando fueron a buscar al
hombre de negocios ya no estaba a romney
sino don al trabajo
[Música]
eso si romney nunca aquí sobre la trama
en la casa blanca esto fue lo que dijo
del presidente cuando éste luchaba por
la nominación republicana hace apenas
cuatro años en 2016
[Aplausos]
y claro que ahora la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es entonces ramón y
crítica todo lo que hace trump pues no
lo cierto es que no
y
él mismo reconoce que algunas de las
medidas económicas de la administración
trump han funcionado en eeuu mucho mejor
de lo que esperaba también ha apoyado la
mayoría de los nombramientos que el
presidente ha hecho en su administración
y en política exterior está de acuerdo
con la estrategias de mano dura hacia
china e irán
en otras palabras está bastante de
acuerdo con lo que podríamos calificar
como la agenda republicana de donald
trump pero detesta sus formas y los
planteamientos que escapan de la típica
agenda republicana y el impeachment el
impeachment fue el momento en el que
romney dijo basta
[Música]
alain prost
solo dos senadores republicanos votaron
con el partido demócrata para la
comparecencia de más testigos entre
ellos testigos como yo envuelto que
además el mismo pidió poder testificar
por supuesto romney era uno de ellos
pero dio igual la mayoría republicana
tumbó la petición y por último en la
votación decisiva romney fue el único
senador republicano que condenó a trump
sin embargo las elecciones de noviembre
están cada vez más cercas y trans que ha
derrotado el partido republicano tendrá
que empezar una nueva etapa y la
pregunta es que podrá portar romney
entonces
romney 2024
la votación de romney en el impeachment
corrige uno de sus mayores errores como
antiguo candidato que es que en lugar de
ir hacia el centro del espacio político
en busca de más votos en aquel momento
eligió contentar al 'tea party' estoy
seguro que todos habéis escuchado hablar
de él
y si el tea party es un movimiento del
partido republicano que hace una década
tenía bastante peso en la organización
en general de su movimiento que
considera que los impuestos son un robo
que promueve una agenda política dura y
sobre todo es un movimiento nacionalista
muy nacionalista en cualquier caso en
romney partido de un plan económico
moderado que poco a poco fue modificando
para terminar presentando un enorme
cambio para que os hagáis una idea una
de sus mayores bazas electorales voy a
poner en marcha una enorme reducción de
impuestos una reducción mucho mayor que
la que ha sido llevada a cabo por trump
fijaos
la reforma fiscal de romney implicaba
una caída del 20% para todos los
contribuyentes la tasa máxima calle al
28 mientras que contra antes se ha
quedado en el 37 al igual que ha hecho
trump ronnie también se comprometió a
llevar a cabo una enorme reducción en el
impuesto sobre beneficios de las
empresas y eso no es todo
romney también prometió una exención
fiscal total para las rentas de capital
que produjeran ganancias menores a 200
mil dólares para compensar toda esta
bajada de impuestos romney se
comprometió a reducir el gasto público
por debajo del 20% del pib
estadounidense
[Música]
vamos en otras palabras romney se
comprometió a llevar a cabo toda una
revolución que hubiera convertido a los
eeuu en uno de los países fiscalmente
más atractivos de todo el mundo
claro que los programas electorales lo
aguantan todo porque a diferencia de
trump romney es un firme defensor del
equilibrio presupuestario y no sé
probablemente de ser presidente y no
hubiera podido llevar a cabo la
totalidad de este cambio pero en
cualquier caso del rumbo estaba claro a
diferencia de trump mitt romney es un
republicano del libro a pesar de que
algunos de sus compañeros de filas le
han reprochado cosas como estas como los
expertos en atención médica de mi ron y
ayudaron a diseñar obamacare pues sí
amigos seguramente sabéis que la reforma
sanitaria de obama ha sido
sistemáticamente criticada por los
republicanos
la consideran muy cara y tras el
intentado cargar varias veces aunque aún
no lo ha conseguido el caso es que el
famoso obama que se inspiró la reforma
de massachusetts que implantó mitt
romney cuando era gobernador la idea
tiene sentido obligar a todo el mundo a
tener seguro médico privado pensando en
dos cosas una que con una mayor demanda
de pólizas las compañías aseguradoras
dan más margen para bajar los precios y
hacerse la competencia a unas con otras
y dos que a quien no pudiera
permitírselo
el estado le daría una ayuda para que
pudiera pagar las pólizas luego estalla
el debate de cómo tiene que ser esta
ayuda y si el estado tiene o no aunque
entrará a competir de hecho tal vez esas
son las dos mayores diferencias a nivel
político de todas las formas del sistema
sanitario de los eeuu hablaremos muy
pronto
en cuanto a la política exterior romney
es un firme defensor del comercio con
méxico y canadá así que seguramente no
hubiera tocado el tratado de libre
comercio de américa del norte y tampoco
se le habría ocurrido poner aranceles a
la unión europea para romney estos
países de norteamérica y europa son
firmes aliados de eeuu y la mano dura y
todas las medidas proteccionistas debe
limitarse a china
y finalmente muchos os estaréis
preguntando pero de verdad romney se
verá con fuerzas para luchar por el
liderazgo del republicanismo post tram
seguramente no pero colaboradores suyos
como obren cas han lanzado american
compás un nuevo movimiento dentro del
partido republicano que aspira a marcar
el camino del centroderecha en los
próximos años y está apuntando nombres
como marco rubio o tom cotton como
candidatos para las próximas primarias
republicanas pero ahora la pregunta para
todos vosotros es os gustaría ver a mitt
romney como candidato a las
presidenciales del 2024 déjame tu
respuesta en los comentarios si este
vídeo te resultó interesante no olvides
darle al botón de like y suscríbete a
visual político una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]